[Music]
starting off this hour
sarasota florida jamie's calling hi
jamie welcome to the dave ramsey show
hello dave how you doing today better
than i deserve what's up in your world
wonderful well dave uh it is no surprise
that
2020 has been a very challenging year
for everybody
freaking dumpster fire absolutely oh
that's a very good way to put it i want
something at least good to come out of
this year
so i'll just go straight to the point i
have
33 000
in savings i owe in my house
32 000 and i'm not gonna lie i'm very
tempted
to pay it off so i could say i ended 20.
and something good that happened in 2020
was that i paid my house off
i understand that i would be depleting
everything but i do
i wanted to let you know that um i do
uh i bring about maybe 60 to 70
000 a year and i do have a steady job
i'm very grateful for that
but obviously you know maybe
i don't know if it would be a good idea
to pay off the home and then
restart um the uh
what's it called emergency emergency
fund and again so
so uh what is your take dude you've done
really good how's it going 33 000
that's more than most people ever see
way to go yeah
good job and um and you only owe 32 on
your house so life's pretty good
you make 60 you got a steady job are you
you're 100 out of debt other than that
right
absolutely yeah i'm on baby step six so
the way you're using your words it
sounds like you're single
uh actually no i am married and with a
child
oh how's your baby yes uh my baby is uh
one and a half
oh perfect okay good very cool well dude
you are what's known as an abundance guy
you think in abundance you don't think
in scarcity you think good things are
gonna happen you don't think bad things
are gonna happen
otherwise you'd be unwilling to go down
to a thousand dollars to your freaking
name with a one and a half year old
okay so uh yeah um
i am two and so i'm kind of like you and
the way i'm wired
uh there's nothing wrong with being
wired either way you just kind of
recognize what you are and say well
that's gonna
affect my tendencies with money rachel's
new book
know yourself know your money talks
about this kind of stuff as a matter of
fact
and so um but the uh uh the thing is
this
i have learned in spite of the fact that
i always believe everything's going to
turn out
it doesn't always on the short term
on the long term it does but on the
short term you can get kicked in the
knee as a matter of fact
with a young family and a one and a half
year old if you in if you
intentionally took yourself all the way
down to almost no money
uh that's like sending out a an email to
murphy
that says come screw up my life
no you're asking for trouble is what i'm
saying
and uh and so the beautiful thing about
when trouble comes and you have 30 grand
in the bank
you just go trouble wronged house dude
go next door to the broke people
right leave me alone trouble i ain't
here when you break something and you
have money it's an inconvenience
when you break something and you're
broke it's a freaking drama
and so that's this is the way things
work and and i love your question and
i'm
the guy that wants to be out of debt
more than anybody else on the planet
so let me ask you this this is october
thank you okay we're good and uh my
brain's coming back now
so could you not save up like three or
four five thousand dollars by the end of
the year
oh sure um i i in fact i actually
i have three more paychecks coming this
year and i'm probably saving about uh
roughly about two grand each month so
six grand
plus one grand is seven thousand dollars
in a household income of sixty
that's a little bit below your three to
six months of expenses but we could
probably say that's an adequate
emergency fund
and we could probably give the mortgage
company the uh the glorified pinky
on uh on new year's eve
sure uh yeah and you would and you
wouldn't you wouldn't have a problem
personally with that you think that
would be a smart idea just kind of get
rid of it
one thousand dollars no that's not smart
eight thousand dollars
yes i can go with okay but even then i'm
going to hold my breath through
february and build that on up a little
bit more because i want a really healthy
emergency fund
because i just found that the emergency
fund is murphy repellent
and so but it's a really good question
number one you got thirty three thousand
dollars your stud
way to go number two you're thinking i
wanna be out of debt number three you
think good things are coming in your
future
and i think it'd be a great way to end
2022
on new year's eve at the party push
submit
on the payment button and be done baby
but i want you to have a the healthier
your emergency fund is between now and
then
the more comfortable you should be with
a baby
it's not me i ain't gonna pay your bills
but i was gonna say the more comfortable
i would be but it
doesn't change my comfort it changes
yours so the more comfortable you should
be
if you have that emergency fund built so
good question
thanks for joining us you know over the
years of doing this show
i've had a lot of questions i'm not
poking fun at jamie at all because he
had a really good question
the number of people who say i want to
do such and such with the emergency fund
if you ever ask yourself that here's a
way to solve it okay
is what you're asking an emergency
if the answer is no then you shouldn't
use the
emergency fund for that
now i think we're going to go on a
vacation we're going to use part of our
emergency fund
you have an emergency vacation
now some of you are so freaking immature
and entitled that you have emergency
vacations but
those of us that are grown-ups we don't
have emergency vacations
although you get to the point sometimes
where life beats the crap out of you and
you feel like you deserve a vacation but
if you don't have any money by
definition you don't deserve it okay
sorry no whining so sharon and i were
laughing about that this weekend
the first thing we bought once we kind
of got in a cool position
was we bought this little bitty brick
house down on the lake it was our
lake house it was just a little bit
better than camping
it's kind of lake house lake house but
we paid cash for it of course
and we would drive down there we had
little kids and little kids man
three of them drive you nuts we love
them but they drive you nuts
and sharon would be getting down there
on friday to the lake house and she
would always just say
i need a vacation i need a vacation
so then we bought the lake house and
she's like you just spent all our
vacation money
i need to no this is your vacation we're
going to the lake house yeah but i got
to work all weekend at the lake house
you know it's not
going to cook and still there's kids are
still here so
i still have to work and so i actually
had this
uh i don't know what you call the thing
like a planter
uh made at the local print shop and they
engrave in the side
of the uh the pottery and it says
sharon's vacation and i put a fern in it
and put it on the front porch
of the lake house we still have that
thing 20 something years later it's in
the new lake house now by the way
and uh which is way better than camping
but uh
yeah sharon's vacation emblazoned in the
side
of the planter we all get there
we all feel like in quotes we need stuff
but it's not a need it's a one it's not
an emergency it's a one this is the dave
ramsey